au fur et à mesure que le nombre de 80
navires us augmentent la peur collective
de l'attraper augmente s'installer c'est
pas une bonne nouvelle le docteur
christine brouh président de l'ordre des
psychologues du québec on vous met à
contribution ce matin parce que des gens
qui nous écoutent et on a beau présenter
des spéciales d opinion scientifique il
ya toujours des gens on dirait que la
part c'est plus fort qu'eux ils
entendent ce qu'ils veulent entendre me
comprennent ce qu'ils veulent comprendre
ce que je fais l'erreur comme ça non pas
du tout c'est à dire que la peur rend
les gens très irrationnel et la panique
et une mauvaise conseillère
parce que le phénomène qui se passe
actuellement c'est que devant la menace
les gens essaient d'avoir du contrôle
sur quelque chose cela dit c'est un faux
sens marcon drôle mais ça donne une
impression d'être capables d'agir sur
quelque chose alors pipi il ya un
phénomène qui est important de
comprendre c'est que la menace est une
chose la réalité objective c'est une
chose mais ce qu'on a fait dans notre
tête
c'est autre chose alors donc il peut y
avoir une disproportion entre le risque
où le danger réel et il la
représentation du danger dans l'esprit
des gens vous demandez est ce qu'un
exercice qu'on peut faire quand on sait
qu'on est sujet à des pannes et qu'il ya
des angoisses comme celle là est ce que
quelque chose qu'on qu'on devrait dire
en nous écoutant aux nouvelles faut bien
qu'on en parle à tous les bulletins de
nouvelles de les mesures de prévention
ont été retirés sa ville qu'on contribue
indirectement naturellement à cette
espèce d'angoissé là on n'arrête pas
d'en parler d'eux mêmes alors est-ce
quelque chose que quelqu'un qui se sent
là
prix pourrait faire pour contrôler mieux
oui tout à fait je pense que d'abord de
se centrer sur les sources de justin
formation c'est une chose à faire parce
que vous savez le lyonnais on est on est
submergé d'informations et un sur deux
sources d'information que des
informations plus crédible que d'autres
alors donc si une personne très près par
la meilleure chose à faire cette chose
sans prise sur une source crédible
d'information un bulletin de nouvelles
par exemple ou une nouvelle la direction
de la santé publique
puis quand j'ai une source crédible ce
que je dis c'est quelqu'un qui est
capable de traduire la réalité de plus
que la science c'est qu'une fois qu'on
fait ça bien écouter une ou 2 1 ou 2
bulletins de nouvelles par jour ça
suffit on n'a pas besoin de laisser la
télé en continu alors donc je pense que
c'est une des choses que les gens peut
faire l'autre chose que les gens peuvent
faire c'est se demander quand je prenais
pis que je vide les étalages de purell
que je chaput de la maison est ce que je
me sens mieux parce que j'ai moins pas
parce qu'en général ces mesures là ne
sont pas efficaces pour contrer la peur
est ce que si on constate qu'on a
quelqu'un dans notre entourage qui était
pris d'une panique comme ça la pire des
choses se disent et arrête de paniquer
parce que loeb on va d'autres on va
partir en week-end ou un argument ce qui
tisse un indice l'accord est ce qu'un
truc pour dire cette personne là est ce
que ce qu'on l'amène à yahoo
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire mais
quand on voit quelqu'un puis dans
n'importe quelle situation quand on voit
quelqu'un qui a une disproportion entre
la réaction qui le puits le risque réel
a on le voit beaucoup chez les jeunes
qui sont très très très anxieux la pire
chose à faire c'est didier qui
s'inquiètent pour rien parce que son
inquiétude est réel donc on peut
refléter ben écoute tolère tolère a
vraiment l'air d'être très pris par
satan l'air de l'inquiéter beaucoup
travers de souffrir de ce qu'est ce que
tu penses qu'il peut aider puis de
regarder avec la personne quelles sont
les mesures qu'elle a prises ce que ça a
été efficace et de la mener vers
d'autres choses qui pourraient peut-être
plus efficace ti comme distraire son
esprit écouter les nouvelles deux fois
par jour et se décentrer un peu chaude
et polarisé un peu de soi parce que
quelqu'un qui devient obnubilé par ça ne
pense qu'à ça puisse rire et la nuit
pour y penser
alors je pense que la meilleure attitude
à avoir c'est de rester vigilant de
rester prudent c'est une belle vertu par
contre la panique ne l'est pas alors
c'est quand on a quelqu'un dans
l'entourage qui est très très très
inquiet d'abord on va pas invalider son
inquiétude parce que l'inquiétude est
réelle la part est réelle mais on voit
les des jusqu'à des polarisée
cette inquiétude lopy peut-être réduire
un questionnement au city est ce que tu
penses que si tu la trappe et satan
portrait par exemple donc essayer de
rétablir les faits pour essayer de voir
dans le pire des scénarios qu'est ce qui
pourrait arriver puis est ce que ce
serait si dramatique que c'est ce qu'il
faut comprendre que quand pour les
personnes ça devient un danger de mort
imminent
c'est sûr que c'est catastrophique mais
la réalité ni poste mais j'espère que
vos conseils vont voir et chacals mais
quelques personnes ceux qui sont ceux
qui souffrent de cette situation là de
cet état là merci beaucoup
malgré la prochaine ça m'a fait plaisir
à voir